the thinking behind how you build an
AdWords campaign is similar to how you
build any campaign just remember to
understand your user and target audience
explore different keywords and different
messaging and keep iterating and
optimizing until you see your desired
results now add words can be a bit
expensive when you're new and starting
out because it's a popular tool and
competition can be high but people keep
searching and they keep paying attention
to the top page results so it's worth
optimizing but don't worry there are
other options you can explore you can
try looking for younger channels like
paid ads on YouTube or Instagram or you
can even explore completely untapped
platforms and find new opportunities for
growth